despite the declining success of the
Batman film franchise in the 90s Warner
Brothers knew that in the right hands
the character was still a gold mine even
though two-time Batman director Joel
Schumacher was interested in making
another installment the studio wanted to
start fresh
that's how Darren Aronofsky got a deal
to pin a screenplay with Frank Miller to
adapt Miller's comic Batman year one
that story arc was eventually made as an
animated film but Aronofsky and Miller
screenplay never got developed here's
why we never got to see it a darker
night the year one comic follows Bruce
Wayne's return to Gotham after 12 years
of travel and training he befriends a
young Jim Gordon and the to take down
gangsters within carmine Falcone's mob
organization despite sightings year 1 as
their inspiration Aronofsky and miller
changed a lot of aspects of the comic
for the screenplay such as making young
Bruce Wayne live as a bum while learning
how to fight crime from books
the big takeaway according to Miller was
that the script just strayed too far
from the traditional Batman storylines
and included elements that took the film
in some dark directions considering
pg-13 is as far as Warner Brothers has
ever gone with Batman this new take on
Batman was just too far from
family-friendly bait-and-switch darren
aronofsky later admitted that he was
never particularly interested in making
a Batman movie he was trying to make a
different movie and he saw year 1 as a
way to get the studio behind his indie
effort he explained it was a kind of
bait and switch strategy I was working
on requiem for a dream and I got a phone
call that Warner Brothers wanted to talk
about Batman at the time I had this idea
for a film called the fountain which I
knew was gonna be this big movie my
theory was if I can write this Batman
film and they can perceive me as a
writer for it then maybe they let me go
ahead even though the Batman movie never
materialized Warner Brothers did finally
give him funding to make the fountain in
2006 so at least some good came out of
the whole thing
tough cast according to the book tales
from development hell Aronofsky's
original pitch is what intrigued Warner
Brothers enough to give him a crack at
the Caped Crusader Aronofsky's idea was
to take the movie in a gritty realistic
direction and his main choice for the
dark gritty hero Clint Eastwood
to ask yourself one question do I feel
lucky
what do you think Dirty Harry in a bad
suit sounds like a great idea but that
casting decision didn't pan out
Aronofsky then settled on gear one as
his source material and according to a
20-17 Yahoo interview he wanted to cast
Joaquin Phoenix as the younger Bruce
Wayne neither of his casting choices
seem to give Warner Brothers much
confidence and Aronofsky later suggested
that the entire concept might have just
been too far ahead of its time
inexperienced with only Robocop 2 and
Robocop 3 a screenwriting credits at
this point Frank Miller admitted he had
a lot to learn about the movie business
he explained the whole process was one
of discovery for me I had to figure out
what they wanted normally somebody like
me if you say you want to make a movie
I'll come up with something that will be
12 hours long and cost 1 billion dollars
to make premature prequel even without
the gritty r-rated tone the two
filmmakers wanted for year 1 there's a
chance the movie would have eventually
been canned anyway prequels and
spin-offs maybe a big market now but in
1999 most movie studios preferred to
Bank on sequels to keep a franchise
going
so when Aronofsky and miller decided to
wipe out the entire Batman film timeline
to start fresh with year 1 the studio
may have been hesitant ultimately the
possibility of new toys and merchandise
might have been the deciding factor in
Warner Brothers agreeing to start
working on the film although that angle
didn't pan out either
Toy bust after giving Warner Brothers
his and Aronofsky's script Millar
quickly realized that Batman year one
probably wasn't going to pan out
describing how the studio reacted he
said I think I heard a streak of horror
at first they were shocked at how bold
it was in other words it wasn't going to
be a movie that sold a lot of toys
Millar spelled it out clearly when he
recalled being told that the project
wasn't moving forward the executive
wanted to do a Batman he could take his
kids to and this wasn't that it didn't
have the toys in it and that's
ultimately what seung-ki or one Warner
Brothers didn't feel like it was the
right fit for a Burger King tie-in
that's too bad because it definitely
sounds like the best Batman film we
never saw thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]